When Disney fans think "Jungle Cruise," they think
riding around in boats, fascinating animals, and
punny dad-jokes galore. All that can be found in
Disney's new film based on the ride, but there's
also so much more. Here's everything only adults
are likely to notice in Disney's "Jungle Cruise."
Adults who remember the music of the
early 1990s will be surprised when they
immediately recognize the first few notes of
the ballad that opens "Jungle Cruise." No,
that song wasn't composed
specifically for the film,
it's the instrumental to power ballad "Nothing
Else Matters," which was released by Metallica in
1991 and has since become a staple of the band's
live shows and one of its most recognizable songs.
According to the credits of "Jungle
Cruise," Metallica reimagined "Nothing
Else Matters" with the film's
composer James Newton Howard,
and the four current members of the band -
James Hetfield, Lars Ulrich, Kirk Hammett,
and Robert Trujillo - are listed as featured
performers on the movie's version of the song.
The ballad's haunting, melancholy
quality makes it especially recognizable,
and while the melody is lovely,
it's not clear why Howard decided
to feature an orchestral version of a
hit from the '90s in the film. In fact,
for those in the know, the inclusion of "Nothing
Else Matters" may be downright distracting,
especially given the movie takes place in 1916
and otherwise features an entirely original
score. On the other hand, it could also serve
as a good excuse to introduce kids to Metallica.
From a bus full of soldiers to German U-Boats,
historical references abound in "Jungle Cruise."
However, unless they're exceptionally young
history buffs, kids are unlikely to be familiar
with the film's numerous nods to World War I.
After all, while World War II's Nazis remain
popular film and TV villains, it's much rarer
for Germans from World War I to be a story's
antagonist, as is the case with Jesse Plemons'
villainous Prince Joachim in "Jungle Cruise."
Part of Lily and MacGregor Houghton's argument
for going after the Tears of the Moon is that it
could revolutionize medicine by healing British
and other Allied soldiers, who were even more
likely to die of disease in the trenches
than they were to be killed by the Germans.
The film also references Kaiser Wilhelm
II, the last emperor of Germany,
who abdicated his throne upon losing the
war in 1918. However, even adults may not
know that Wilhelm's youngest son really was
named Joachim. As far as we know, though,
the real-life Prince Joachim never took a U-Boat
up the Amazon to search for a legendary tree.
Throughout the movie, Lily encounters
more than her fair share of overt sexism.
She's first introduced in the balcony of a
theater where her brother is presenting a speech
she clearly wrote to an academic guild made up
entirely of men. And even though she has a Ph.D.,
her knowledge and abilities are often questioned,
as is her resolve to go after the Tears of theMoon.
Even her brother worries about who would
take care of her if she went to the Amazon alone,
although she's clearly more than
capable of taking care of herself.
In addition, her choice to wear pants, a
rarity in 1916, is called out repeatedly.
Frank finds her choice to be so exceptional
that he even gives her the nickname "Pants."
Kids these days may be surprised by the treatment
the obviously smart and determined Lily endures.
Adults, however, will know quite well that
blatant discrimination against women was
more or less the global standard, making her
the story's underdog just by being a woman.
Soon after Frank and Lily first meet,
Frank is revealed to have lied to her
about his true identity. However, he
regains her confidence when he goes up
against a jaguar who menaces the patrons
at the restaurant where they're dining.
After all, if Frank can take on a jaguar, he's
certainly capable of taking her up the Amazon.
"Careful. They can smell fear."
However, Lily missed one thing: Jaguars
and other animals are unlikely to attack
humans unless they've been directly threatened,
which this jaguar clearly was not. As a result,
many adults in the audience may realize that
since the jaguar wasn't acting in self-defense,
it's unclear why it came into the restaurant, much
less attacked the large gathering of people there.
Given the fear and adrenaline Lily
might have felt in that moment,
she seems to have failed to notice that
given those variables, while Frank's
ability to wrestle the jaguar seemed impressive,
something else was clearly going on. And indeed,
the movie soon reveals that Frank and the
jaguar, who's named Proxima, are in cahoots,
with Proxima attacking Frank in order
to secure him the job as Lily's skipper.
Early in their trip down the Amazon, Frank's
boat La Quila sails past a pod of long-peaked
dolphins that all bear little resemblance to
the bottlenose dolphins many people are most
familiar with. However, adults may be aware
that there are numerous dolphin species,
and one of them is the Amazon river dolphin
shown in the movie. This freshwater dolphin
is native to the Amazon and is also sometimes
referred to as the pink river dolphin,
or in Brazil, the boto cor de
rosa due to its pinkish hue.
In the movie, Lily refers to the
dolphins by their scientific name,
inia geoffrensis. Meanwhile,
Frank's identification
of them as "encantado" evokes a myth about
Amazon river dolphins being shape-shifters,
and more broadly refers to the many other legends
surrounding the species, including the one Frank
relates: that looking into a pink river dolphins'
eyes will lead to a lifetime of nightmares.
Almost 20 years ago, another movie inspired by
a boat-based Disney theme park ride premiered:
"Pirates of the Caribbean: The Curse of
the Black Pearl." You may have heard of it.
"Savvy?"
While many younger children are
unlikely to have seen that 2003 film,
adults may get a sense of deja vu when watching
"Jungle Cruise" due to the fact that the film's
supernatural storyline largely overlaps
with that of the earlier movie. Much like
the pirates who were cursed with eternal
life after they took the wrong treasure,
the conquistadors who went after the Tears
of the Moon in "Jungle Cruise" were cursed
with eternal life for attempting to take that
treasure. Inevitably, just like Captain Barbossa
and his crew in "Pirates," Aguirre and his
allies wish to break their immortal bonds.
If that weren't enough, the mid-movie revelation
that Frank himself is also cursed with unending
life because 400 years ago he was Aguirre's
map maker parallels the eventual revelation in
"Pirates" that Jack Sparrow is undead because he
was the captain of the Black Pearl before Barbossa
and his crew mutinied. The resemblance between
the "Jungle Cruise" and "Pirates" mythology may
raise some adults' eyebrows, not to mention make
them wonder why the powers that be at Disney
felt the need to include a supernatural
plotline in a film based on a ride that,
unlike "Pirates," never included anything
that could be interpreted as supernatural.
"Jungle Cruise" nods to several well-known
films that only adults are likely to notice.
In addition to "Pirates of the Caribbean,"
there are hat tips to 1999's "The Mummy,"
the "Indiana Jones" films, and
"Romancing the Stone." However,
if there's one classic that especially influenced
the new film, it's 1951's "The African Queen."
Theme park buffs will know the "Jungle
Cruise" homage to the Humphrey Bogart
and Katharine Hepburn-led classic is no
accident; Walt Disney was partially inspired
to create the Jungle Cruise attraction
in Disneyland by "The African Queen."
Given that connection, it's not surprising
that the new movie bears a noticeable
resemblance to the older film. Both have a
plot that revolves around a skipper becoming
involved with a brother and sister who require
passage down a waterway during World War I.
"My brother and I are
looking for passage upriver."
"Please go away."
"I have a lot of money."
"The African Queen" influence can also be
seen in the dynamic between Frank and Lily,
who constantly butt heads only to come
to respect and then fall for one another,
just like Bogart and Hepburn's characters.
Adults who notice the connection between the
two films may use it as an opportunity to
introduce their kids to the 1951 classic.
While Disney has attempted to be more inclusive
by incorporating more openly gay characters in
films like the live-action remakes of
"Beauty and the Beast" and "Cruella,"
it's done so in such a subtle way that
plenty of people wouldn't even notice.
Unfortunately, "Jungle Cruise" has the
same issue. The film includes perhaps
the most overtly "out" character yet in the
form of Lily's clothes-obsessed brother,
MacGregor. However, it tiptoes lightly
around the issue of his sexuality.
Toward the middle of the film, MacGregor
confesses to Frank that although he doesn't
share his sister's belief in the
legend of the Tears of the Moon,
he sticks by Lily because unlike everyone
else in his life, she didn't abandon him
when she learned about his sexuality. However,
the whole story is told through implication;
while adults will likely pick up on
what MacGregor's saying, his wording
is vague enough that many kids are unlikely to
realize what exactly he's even talking about.
In the film's third act, Lily is forced to
swim for the first time after Frank finds an
underwater chamber with a lever in it that
will lead them to the Tears of the Moon.
What kids and even some adults may not realize
is that when Frank kisses Lily for the first
time while she's trapped underwater, it's
not for any romantic reason. After all,
given the pair's will-they-or-won't-they
dynamic throughout the story, the kiss can
easily be interpreted as the characters finally
admitting their feelings for one another.
However, that's not Frank's intention. As
he pantomimes, he's simply trying to provide
Lily with air so she can stay underwater
long enough to pull the chamber's lever.
Of course, even adults would be justified
in interpreting Frank as having something
of an ulterior motive here, especially since
the exchange of oxygen between the characters
looks more like a smooch than
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation.
Kids who've been lucky enough to visit a Disney
park may pick up on some of the film's direct
references to the Jungle Cruise ride. When
Frank goes under a makeshift waterfall early
in the film and triumphantly introduces "the
backside of water" with a declaration that
it's "the eighth wonder of the world," everyone
familiar with the ride will smile knowingly.
However, there are some less obvious nods
to the attraction that kids may miss,
including a shocking number of ridiculous new
puns and an early reference to Dr. Albert Falls,
the man the ride's waterfall
is supposedly named after.
"The rocks you see here in
the river are sandstone, but
some people just take them for granite."
Plus, when Frank is first introduced guiding
a jungle cruise of tourists down the Amazon,
he essentially functions as a skipper in the theme
park ride. As his boat continues along the water,
it's revealed that Frank has rigged up his
own makeshift Jungle Cruise attraction,
complete with a fake hippo,
in order to provide the same
thrilling -- and silly -- experience
as the ride Disney Parks fans adore.
"It's one of my
boulder attractions."
Interestingly, after delays due to the
coronavirus pandemic, "Jungle Cruise"
is hitting theaters just as Disneyland
opens an updated version of the ride,
and the revised experience no longer includes
characters that are featured in the film.
After years of complaints over the
attraction's depictions of native people,
Disneyland removed some of the audio-animatronic
characters that appear toward the end of the ride,
including Trader Sam, who is willing to exchange
"two of his shrunken heads for one of yours."
The updated ride also excised a group
of headhunters who are characterized
as savages and throw spears at the ride vehicle.
Yet "Jungle Cruise" features both a
gender-swapped Trader Sam and a group
of supposedly threatening Indigenous people.
While the story avoids shading into racism
by revealing that the natives' behavior is
all just part of a scheme cooked up with
Frank to make his jungle cruises more
exciting, adults who keep up on Disney
parks news will know that these references
to the ride are now things of the past.
"Well, I look forward to disappointing you."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.